stick around to the end of the video for
an exciting announcement
[Music]
this is where i was like yeah this is
what you're doing
[Music]
i definitely look back on that video and
i'm like we were babies
we had no idea what we were talking
about
[Music]
my baby's father is still involved in
our lives
three
two
one go
i think last time i was all the way over
there
everything's changed i was 14 i got
pregnant and my boyfriend was 14 as well
and after the paternity test the court
introduced visitation she was 10 months
old
sorry she was 10 months old and she
finally got to meet her dad and um
the visitation kept up for a while but
recently he's been getting into fights
and i'd rather do it alone than with him
at this point it was really hard before
and it's done a complete 180. we were
able to get through everything
there was a lot of things to get through
and i had to let go of a lot of pain
that i was holding towards him
that was directly affecting like
co-parenting because with co-parenting
it's not about what they did to you it's
about
you have a kid together and he stepped
up to the role and he's an awesome dad
and i am so grateful yeah my boyfriend
is still completely involved in our
daughter's life and
for me i'm like so proud of how he has
grown as a father because he just really
was not prepared whatsoever
and it really took like
a lot of like just time and like
patience with
with him and her to just like grow that
bond because i know they struggled at
first now he's in school but it's still
awesome to know that he's like
completely like capable of watching her
relationships change after you have a
child
three
two
one go
yeah completely like friendship wise
it's so hard to maintain like
friendships that you had before you were
a bomb and be able to like go out the
same and hang out with friends the same
but then i do have friends who have like
stuck with me throughout being pregnant
and having a baby and those are now her
aunties
my friendships all relationships they
either went positive or negative like
none stayed with my husband
our relationship has gotten stronger
since the last video honestly we've both
emotionally have matured a lot and with
my parents and his parents he
we've gotten closer because i feel like
when we started our relationship we were
kind of like ugh i don't wanna go see my
mom but now like all we wanna do is be
with both our moms i cried immediately
from my mom and how badly i treated her
as a teenager before i had my daughter
and i cried for my sister how i treated
them teachers all of the things that we
were given and i was entitled to
now after having a kid it all changed
yeah my view on relationships just like
i said in the first video just changed
just what their purpose is especially
when i got thrown into being a young
single mom and just lost what felt like
everybody including my family for a
period but thank god they all came back
but that was just complete loneliness so
i look at relationships as a huge
commitment you know something that you
two people go okay i'm ready to pour
into you and are you ready to pour into
me
i want to have more kids
three
two
one
go
whoa okay
i'm surprised everybody said yes
so in the last video i was i think
about a month into being a mom like he
was a newborn and then five months later
i got pregnant again wow yeah she was
planned to
we just don't have a lot of babies in
our family and i didn't want him to grow
up alone and right now i'm on somewhat
degree because two is a lot it's scary
to have more like i don't want to plan
the next one
eventually i do want kids not anytime
soon because i'm still trying to get my
degree and my boyfriend's in law school
at this point even though i'm excited to
have kids like a part of me is like crap
you have to go through the baby phase
again and like all that but i know it'll
be easier being older and more stable
i'm excited for that once you get to
four you're gonna be like i miss
i miss that when she did not have an
opinion on anything that was the good
time so strongly agree i would like to
adopt i would like a small village of
children
i would like all ages just running
around everywhere i think kids are so
awesome and they're so
good at teaching you things that you
didn't even know you needed to learn i
feel like my whole life god's just gonna
be sending what's your
preferred number i'm curious is it like
more than seven
seven is my preferred number oh my god
it's a perfect number yeah we're gonna
have a school bus just filled with kids
i cannot wait to see it i love that now
that i've seen what it's like to live
alone and be a parent not still be at my
mom's house
it's a lot more and
i do want more kids but once everly's
grown up
i want my other kids to be grown up so i
have time to be myself and kind of
separate myself from being a parent
still be a parent obviously i'm still
going to talk to my kids after they're
18. if i just keep popping out babies i
feel like
i'm never going to learn who i truly am
to the fullest extent
having a child was a massive financial
burden
three
two
one go
i feel like my situation is really
unique because i do youtube
and that's how i earn my income i also
do other things but youtube being the
main one but without her i would not
have had this channel i wouldn't have
found a place where i want to try to
inspire other moms but also at the same
time try to prevent teen pregnancy
before i got pregnant i i was going
nowhere i was depressed i
it was bad i feel like
i was blessed with opportunity that i
was able to plan it and have some
savings so it wasn't really a burden my
husband and i learned how to budget we
learned how to make investments but
behind the scenes you have all this
whispering and talking like oh teen mom
no money and immediately correlate it
but
the biggest child care expense i have
had to pay i mean
a lot of people don't realize taking
care of your kids that's that is
expensive there are there's school
there's work and things that i could do
and want to do that i don't because
slash can't because i'm with my daughter
all the time so i have to be very
flexible at what i can actually do with
her i'm so happy to do so but going to
court with my child's father was the
most expensive thing i've ever gone
through my entire life and wasn't debt
for
and just nobody talks about that if
you're gonna have a kid there's
weird
expenses that will pop up like when my
daughter was born there weren't like a
lot of costs because i was so blessed to
be able to like breastfeed exclusively i
feel like that's one of the biggest
costs like when you have a newborn is
like how expensive formula is so i feel
like i never
felt the financial burden until i was
like i have to go to work and she has to
go to school it is a financial burden
because i need someone to watch her i
don't i don't have family my my
boyfriend's in school this is the how it
is for a lot of moms that you you get
your paycheck and like almost a majority
of it goes straight to child care and so
it's like why am i even working if it's
all going to child care but at the same
time you do need that like surplus
amount that you get you know
i worry i'm not a good parent
three
two
one go
wow
go you
[Laughter]
i think it comes down to what you define
good parenting as and when it comes down
to it a good parent is someone who loves
their child and will do everything to
support them there are times where i
feel kind of worried that oh crap did i
yell too much a day or something
but in the end i love my child and i
think that's what defines a good parent
thinking of your parents do you try to
emulate your parents as you parent your
children or do you run from that idea i
personally run from it just because it
was a lot of physical disciplining
growing up and it was more
mentally draining i feel like my parents
priority was just
be good at school like and here's food
and here's a house and
you're
perfectly well taken care of because you
have your necessities but i feel like
emotions should be added in that
category not just food water and shelter
my parents were good parents and they
were very loving but
their priorities as parents was very
different i think the old way of
thinking was if your kids listen to you
then you're a good parent if they follow
the rules then you're a good parent
successful adults are not ones that
follow the rules quote unquote they're
people that think outside of the box
that make good decisions because they're
the right decisions not because
everyone's watching them the way of
thinking back then was so different and
they did the best with what they had and
i very much love them for that but i'm
trying to do it differently
having a baby changed my life for the
better
three
two
one
go
so before i had my daughter i was
thinking of what my suicide note was
going to say i was not in a good place
she saved my life it not only got better
but it was saved because
i had a reason to stay alive and work on
myself i had a reason to become a better
person and heal
since then my life has gotten so amazing
in ways that i never imagined possible
because of being a parent
it's no longer like i'm just doing this
for myself i mean i can't compare to you
guys yet because i don't have my baby
yet but like i mean it's as simple as
getting up and going to my class but i
have a whole new motivation to do
something as simple as that and strive
for my best so
of course i never planned for her to
come but um when i did find out i was
pregnant and then once i had her it was
like this like insurmountable amount of
joy and love that just suddenly fills
your heart
being young and having a child like
there's challenges that come with that
but when you look at the big picture of
things like we're able to love them and
support them and breeze these wonderful
little human beings yeah i see
my life back then and i was pretty cold
with babies and like the people around
me i wouldn't really say i love you that
much and now i'm just like
grabbing cheeks and hugging every single
person i have the opportunity to hug
because life is short and you realize
that when you have babies because we
were just talking about how old they've
gotten since the last video and it
breaks my heart that they're just gonna
go up from here like there's no pausing
time
can i yeah because i know it's annoying
[Music]
hey good humans do you love spectrum if
so you're in luck we're actually making
a game you can play at home with your
friends and family where you can answer
questions like this
having a college degree is overrated i
agree i have one and it's never helped
me in any way of my life
[Music]
oh
put this back